[Música]
que o pac já dizia algumas coisas nunca
mudam
são regras do mundão perdi a conta de
quantos estende há bolsas eu digo que
ora são taxistas pergunta mais que
policiais a mim e sim em descritível
como é ruim
nasci vilão só veneno com incentivo que
me dão errado torcendo virá mesmo só na
cara levando currículo para a pé porque
onde eu moro buzzo não para pé de barro
meio-dia inspirando piada nos boy
transpirando medo nas tia
tudo é tão óbvio você não vê que vai
juntando ingrediente da bomba relógio eu
sinto dou eu sinto ódio é quente tem nem
saber o nome dessa gente católica de bem
linda
você já notou pior que nem falei a cor
ainda seja faz idéia do que é ver vídeo
subir alguém correr quando avistava você
não fez não faz idéia explica a
assistente social que pai de gente igual
a gente não sabe exatamente só paulo e
que educa nóis na escola estadual joga
na cara todas as manhã que ganha mal e é
incrível
quantos de nós sentar no fundo da sala
para ver se fica invisível calcula o
prejuízo em nossas crianças o que quando
crescer vão ter cabelo liso sem debater
os fatos da fama da minha cor que fecha
as portas
zelador do campeonato você sabe o quanto
é comum dizer que preta ladrão antes
mesmo de a gente saber o que é um na
porta de quem leva a discórdia se
orgulha da entidade que nunca foi posta
à prova eu queria vê lá esses bandos de
tiriça para terezinha que essa merda de
senso de justiça
boa noite pinheiros mas eu quero que o
capão redondo discuti-la um lado a noite
pinheiros
eu sou o andré luis eu tenho 22 anos e
eu sou especialista em construções do
zero e hoje eu queria apresentar um
pouquinho da caminhada não para servir
como exemplo referência ou inspiração
para caminhos até mesmo para dividir com
acho que quando a gente consegue
compartilhar a gente cresce
eu nasci num conjunto habitacional ela
no capão redondo que se chama inferninho
e desde criança eu tive um diferencial
muito grande por ter meu pai e minha mãe
sob o mesmo teto e é louco pensar que
isso me fez chegar 90 mais longe do que
99% das pessoas que viviam meu redor
você consegue comparar a ausência do pai
na preferia é pelas datas comemorativas
e assim sem identificar pode pode
mostrar mesmo dia das mães festa
comercial todo mundo falando tal comprar
alguma coisa passou a rainha
minha mãe minha vida faz uma tatuagem aí
sim o nome de sua mãe chega dia dos pais
a mãe também é pai tá comprar alguma
coisa pra sua mãe e eu ficava olhando
pra isso falou assim nossa velho e
porque quando se é criança não consegue
entender desigualdade social
você tá lá seus pais não passando veneno
só que não entende
não entendi porque não tem só quando
você entra na adolescência e chega no
ensino fundamental 2 você consegue
perceber o quanto a sociedade ela é fria
e você percebe que está no meio de uma
guerra com um canivete e eu na escola eu
não era o clássico popular quem era
popular na escola por favor levanta a
mão rapidamente
só dois gente quem era nerd e quem não
levantou era a mão é dos nem nem popular
nem nerd nem ninguém sentirá falta
correto eu fazia parte desse núcleo
só que eu tinha um diferencial eu sabia
contar histórias
só que eu também queria ter as coisas e
eu percebia que o meio da sala não era o
seu
pelas meninas não era o que chamava
atenção porque não tinha algumas coisas
que a galera jogava importante como um
tênis de marca uma calça e aí que o
mesmo com minha família estruturada em
eu mudei as pessoas com quem convivia os
hábitos dessas pessoas e os lugares
eu me envolvi com as drogas por
curiosidade porque existia tabu existe
tabu até hoje de não conversar sobre
coisas que têm que ser conversadas
os meus pais tivessem falado pra mim o
quanto as drogas seria destrutivo para
mim eu nunca teria usado a minha mãe e
meu pai tivesse falado sobre sexo comigo
não teria um filho já só que a gente
leva isso como tabu e eu comecei acabou
a aula começou a usar droga
e aí um dia quando você vai conseguir
nesse caminho você a conta chega né pra
mim ela chegou no dia 5 de julho quem
sabe o que se comemora no dia 5 de julho
5 de julho quem o agente é íntimo gente
só compartilha minha vida com vocês
ninguém lembrou meu aniversário valeu
billy salva de palmas para ele por favor
decepcionado com vocês viu e aí no dia
do aniversário em 2011 eu dei entrada no
hospital campo limpo com início de
overdose e eu fiquei muito frustrado por
não ter morrido porque eu eu achava que
na minha cabeça que não ia conseguir
chegar a lugar nenhum e eu lembro quando
estava saindo do hospital para uma
senhora que provavelmente não conhecia
da igreja da minha época de coroinha
ela parou na minha frente e me deu um
abraço
ela foi bem assim estava aqui eu fiquei
com aquela cara de ti
e não entende nada e ela foi embora
só que aquele abraço ele mudou minha
vida dias depois eu queria convidar você
para fazer um exercício do abraço
olha pra mim tá do lado aí dá um belo de
um abraço nele e falar mano noite bonita
tudo bem se não conhece gente vamos lá
boa tranquilo não precisa beijar não
precisa beijar ó e aí quando eu voltei
pra casa eu falei eu vou mudar de
perspectiva
eu vou fazer alguma coisa pra sair da
miséria para sair da pobreza
minha mãe nunca vai trabalhar para
ninguém eu falei tá bom vou fazer isso
mas agora como voltei pra escola estava
com seis meses de falta naquele ano e eu
precisava fazer alguma coisa pra passar
o primeiro ano
mesmo não sabendo um ler e escrever
direito era só ir lá e fazer o trabalho
que eu passava e aí eu comecei uma rádio
dentro da escola
na minha escola que era presidente café
filho e é quem tinha até bordão posso
fazer pra vocês rádio café filho seu
futuro começa aqui era louco gente
porque a rádio dentro da escola para
quem estava fazendo e fazendo lá tocando
música era muito louco
só que quem estava do lado de fora me
escutava nada que acha horrível
quem já teve rádio na escola sabe como é
que é e um belo dia apareceu um doido
que fazer um sabão de arroz e virou pra
mim e falou você tem noção do que está
fazendo
eu falei estou tocando música no
intervalo
aí vamos lá vou te levar para alguns a
família o cara tem grana mano me levou
para mostrar o bom prato beleza a escala
começou a voltar de novo na escola é um
belo dia ele me falou vamos ali que eu
quero te apresentar um lugar que é uma
escola visionária a diretora é incrível
tenho um cara incrível lá também vamos
lá e também tem almoço meio dia para
almoçar lá eu fui e essas três pessoas
estão aqui hoje eu sou muito grato muito
grata a elas
mestre de cerimônia bruno capão que me
levou pra mostrar bom prato tem vergonha
na cara é a dona eda luiz que me
inspirou a começar o processo porque
quando cheguei pra mostrar pra ela um
fanzine que nem meu era ela falou assim
que incrível quero que faça como os
jovens e nunca vi alguém que botar tanta
fé em mim nem eu acreditava falava nossa
el billy que sempre foi muito sincero
com o processo e aí o comércio com a
rádio e eu acredito que a criatividade
ela vem da necessidade vamos repetir
isso junto à criatividade vem da
necessidade vocês agora eu tinha um
amigo que ele era cadeirante ele tinha
deixado de pagar escola por conta da
cadeira que tinha quebrado o maikon
douglas e aí a gente falou mano
vamos pedir dinheiro pra conseguir a
cadeira por maicon
todo mundo ficou olhando aqui pra minha
cara tá beleza
eu fui pra casa comecei a pensar falar e
mano audiovisual cinema tá na moda vem
todo mundo está assistindo
peguei os equipamentos emprestados da
escola
montamos lá um cenário e gravamos a
história do mico e lançamos a campanha
eu ajudo maicon é um bando de moleques
de 15 anos de idade sem um real no bolso
a gente lançou no orkut quem aqui lembra
do orkut 2012 a gente
lançamos no youtube em três semanas a
gente conseguiu oito mil reais para
comprar cadeira do maicon com a ajuda de
uma pá de gente eu falei nossa os
moleque é liso e jovem tem muito tem um
problema muito grande
o adolescente jovem tal não pode eu
brinco até com a galera do que inclui
porque às vezes quando a gente é jovem a
gente faz alguma coisa incrível a gente
ferro carril restante que a gente acha o
salvador da pátria
eu falei agora os caras do capão redondo
vai vir aqui na minha casa falar comigo
e eu parei de produzir para de fazer a
galera como o trampo e eu estava lá com
14 14 anos de idade
falei gente meu deus e aí eu comecei no
meu quarto de reforma sem nada com a
coleção de não tinha porque não tinha
câmera não tinha equipamento não tinha
celular
a tv do capão uma tv que não falava de
tragédia no capão redondo e foi muito
louco esse processo porque pensar que as
periferias elas têm coisas boas
só que em 2012 a gente não falava sobre
as coisas boas porque tinha muita
informação só negativa
e você tinha que mentiu é rigidamente o
endereço pra conseguir um emprego
as pessoas não tinha autoestima e aí a
gente começou a gravar com os artistas
locais com a galera das ongs com a dona
maria da associação comunitária e com
isso a gente foi mais do que produzir um
conteúdo para a internet mostrando que
aquelas pessoas elas eram importantes
para os seus territórios e não era tv
doctor dava voz pra elas eram a elas que
davam voz pra tv doc por um bando de
moleques não sabia de nada e aí a tv do
que ela cresceu
hoje a gente já depois de oito anos a
gente já fez mais de 240 produções
autorais entre documentários curta
metragens com todas as prestações de
serviços que a gente já fez ao longo
desses anos oficinas editais
a gente já circulou mais de 500 mil
reais com jovens gerando renda
aprendendo uma profissão
só que para pensar fazer vídeo para
internet é sensacional
só que ainda um contato superficial de
uma pessoa com uma tela com o aparelho
eu me desafiava acinte e trocar o que
estava aprendendo as oportunidades que
eu estava adquirindo e aí vem o segundo
projeto da tv tokyo doc inclui que
começa lá não seja campo limpo
inspirado em paulo freire eu queria que
minha mãe tem de si qual é o som de
educação por paulo de paulo freire
eu começo remodelando o papel do
educador e aluno não tem mais o educador
não tem mais professor todo mundo decide
ea gente divide o curso em três fases
olhar experimentar e fazer levando em
consideração que o jovem ele antes de
começar qualquer coisa ele tem que olhar
para si próprio para o seu território
para a organização que ele está inserido
para os três pontos ele entender onde
ele está
porque se a gente não sabe a gente tá a
gente nunca vai conseguir ir para lugar
nenhum
na segunda fase que é experimentar aí a
gente joga os equipamentos na mão deles
valem aprendam que a gente aprendeu
vetorial no youtube
mexe no equipamento seja responsável o
da autonomia
a gente fala o jovem não é responsável
com o processo
só que a gente não dá autonomia projovem
e construir as coisas e aí sabe quem
vence numa guerra carnal é o tráfico
porque o tráfico vira um moleque de 14
anos e fala
tó gerencia ea gente fica com medo de
colocar recurso de colocar a
responsabilidade em cima de moleque e
eles querem responsabilidade e na última
fase que é o fazer
eles pegam todo o conhecimento que eles
adquiriram ao longo do processo e criam
ou mini doc ou um curta metragem ou um
livro que tem a ver com a realidade dele
e ele se vê no produto materializa nesse
processo já passaram mais de 1500 jovens
mais de 30 organizações e eu não assinei
nada precisam é que eles que ensinaram
como lidar como respeitar como aceitar
como ouvir e eles fazem com que o
processo eles fosse intenso tanto que eu
não pensava mais em comer não pensava
assim sair de roller
eu não pensava em curtir minha juventude
eu só pensava como é que a gente
consegue transformar tudo isso que a
gente está fazendo de maneira que seja
única
e aí eu venho a inquietação de novo eu
preciso fazer com que esses moleques
estão lá dentro da ong conectam dentro
do projeto eles cheguem mais longe
porque eu tive várias oportunidades de
cursos eventos e versões coisas que
fizeram eu trazer um conhecimento e
compartilhar com eles
só que nesses cursos que eu tinha acesso
e que eram caros não tinha preto
estudando tinha preto servir no chá
preto na segurança tinha preto limpando
em cima dessa desse questionamento de
não ter preto comecei a pensar como é
que a gente consegue conectar as pessoas
essas organizações conectar os
empreendedores conectar esses jovens com
a oportunidade
desenvolvimento e tem uma frase que eu
gosto muito que diz que a gente deve
encarar o desafio não torcer pra que ele
desapareça e eu conheci um empresário um
grande amigo meu que tinha um sonho de o
cruzeiro às cadeiras vazias não diminuir
não abaixar dizer a todo custo que vocês
já fizeram na vida de vocês
tinha uma cadeira vazia que podia ser
ocupada por alguém
e aí nasce o educadoras uma plataforma
que conecta empreendedores sociais
agentes de preferir jovens a
oportunidade de cursos dentro da rede
privada
a gente abre espaço para pessoas que
querem transformar que vão multiplicar
esse conhecimento
o educadoras ele começou faz um mês a
gente tem dez parceiros de beneficiados
dez instituições que estão doando
cadeiras e de doações a gente já
conseguiu mais de 200 mil reais só
ocupando cadeira vazia
a nossa meta até o final do ano é
conseguir bater um milhão de cadeiras
vazias impactar mais de cinco mil
pessoas
eu acredito que a gente é consegue fazer
isso porque como eu disse no início pra
vocês eu sou um cara bem simples
o menino qualquer mas eu sou
especialista em construções do zero para
terminar o tempo tornou eu queria
convidar vocês para recitar um poema
comigo você está o pão estão com a cara
de tipo assim
mande notícias do mundo de lá tá tudo
bem aí gente
eu digo para vocês é amor paz mas era
apenas um moleque que ainda sonhava
ninguém botava fé nem esperava nada
tudo era tão distante não tinha internet
um pouco de esperança ea vontade do
moleque o quarto da sua irmã ele pediu
para usar criou uma tv para me preocupar
com isso o usuário louco isso não muda
pra família tentando fugir da tragédia
garantida
vários no caminho ele viu se perder
andré meu parceiro onde está você tem
que trabalhar para ter um futuro eu não
tinha nada então apostei tudo vamos
acima que podemos mudar nossa vida só a
gente pode transformar para de esperar
só pelo futuro você tem papel caneta
então escreva um novo rumo gratidão
galera
[Aplausos]
[Música]